Hello world is Saraj and the
mathematics of machine learning.
Is it necessary to know math for
machine learning? Absolutely.
Machine learning is math.
It's all math. In this video,
I'm going to help you understand why we
use math in machine learning by example,
machine learning is all about creating
an algorithm that can learn from data to
make a prediction.
That prediction could be what an object
and a picture looks like or what the
next price for gasoline might be in
a certain country or what the best
combination of drugs to cure
a certain disease might be.
Machine learning is built on mathematical
prerequisites and sometimes it feels
like learning them might be a
bit overwhelming, but it isn't.
Or is it? No, it's not. As long as
you understand why they're used,
it'll make machine
learning a lot more fun.
You can have a full time job doing machine
learning and not know a single thing
about the math behind the functions
you're using, but that's no fun is it?
You want to know why something works and
why one model is better than another.
Machine learning is powered
by the diamond of statistics.
Calculus,
linear Algebra and probability.
Statistics is at the core of everything.
Calculus tells us how to
learn and optimize our model.
Linear Algebra makes running
these algorithms feasible
on massive datasets and
probability helps predict the
likelihood of an event occurring.
So let's start from scratch
with an interesting problem.
The problem is to predict the price
of an apartment in an up and coming
neighborhood in New York City. Let's
say Harlem. Shout out to Harlem,
Yo west side represent.
Okay.
Let's say that all will know when we
eventually make a prediction is the price
per square foot of a given apartment.
That's the only marker we'll use to
predict the price of the apartment as a
whole.
And lucky for us,
we've got a Dataset of apartments
with two columns. In the first column,
we've got the price per square foot
of an apartment. In the second column,
we've got the price of
the apartment as a whole.
There's got to be some kind of correlation
here and if we build a predictive
model,
we can learn what that correlation is so
that in the future if all were given is
the price per square foot of a house,
we can predict the price of it.
If we were to graph out this data,
let's graph this out with the x axis,
measuring the price per
square foot and the y axis,
measuring the price of a house.
It would be a scatter plot.
Ideally we could find a
line that intersects as many
data points as possible and
then we could just plug in some input
data into our line and outcomes.
The prediction, poof. In mathematics,
the field of statistics
acts as a collection of
techniques that extract useful
information from data.
It's a tool for creating an
understanding from a set of numbers.
Statistical inference is the process
of making a prediction about a larger
population of data based
on a smaller sample,
as in what can we infer about a
population's parameters based on a sample
statistic. Sounds pretty similar to what
we're trying to do right now. Right?
Since we're trying to create a line,
we'll use a statistical inference
technique called linear regression.
This allows us to summarize and study
the relationship between two variables.
A little mountain one variable x is
regarded as the independent variable.
The other variable y is regarded
as the dependent variable.
The way we can represent linear regression
is by using the equation y equals mx
plus B.
Why is the prediction x is the input B
as the point where the line intersects.
The y axis and m is the slope of the line.
We already know what the x value
would be and why is our prediction.
If we had M and B we would have a full
equation plug and play easy prediction,
but the question is how
do we get these variables?
The naive way would be for us to just
try out a bunch of different values over
and over and over again and plug
the line over time using our eyes.
We could try and estimate just
how well fit the line we draw is,
but that doesn't seem efficient does it?
We do know there exists some ideal values
for M and B such that the line when
drawn using those values would
be the best fit for our dataset.
Let's say we did have a bunch of time
on our hands and we decided to try out a
bunch of predicted values for M and B.
We need some way of measuring how
good our predicted values are.
Will need to use what's
called an error function.
An error function will tell us how far
off the actual why value is from our
predicted value.
There are lots of different types of
statistical error functions out there,
but let's just try a simple one called
least squares. This is what it looks like.
We'll make an apartment price prediction
for each of our data points based on
our own intuition.
We can use this function to double
check against the actual apartment price
value. It will subtract each
predicted value from the actual value.
Then it will square each of
those differences. The sigma.
That little [inaudible] looking thing
denotes that we're doing this not just for
one data point,
but for every single data point.
We have m data points to be specific.
This is our total error value.
We can create a three dimensional graph.
Now we know the x axis and the y axis,
they will be all the potential
m and B values respectively,
but let's add another axis.
The Z axis and on the axis would be all
the potential error values for every
single combination of M and B.
If we were to actually graph this out,
it would look just like this,
this kind of bowl like shape cup.
It firmly in your hand like a nice bowl.
If we find that data point at the bottom
of the bowl, the smallest error value,
that would be our ideal m and B values.
That would give us the line of best fit,
but how do we actually do that?
Now we need to borrow from the
math discipline known as calculus,
the study of change. It's
got an optimization technique
called gradient descent.
That will help us discover the
minimum value iteratively it.
We'll use the error for a given data point
to compute what's called the gradient
of our unknown variable and we can
use the gradient to update to our two
variables.
Then we'll move on to the next data point
and repeat the process over and over
and over again.
Slowly like a ball rolling down a bowl.
We'll find what our minimum value is.
See,
calculus helps us find the direction
of change in what direction should we
change the unknown variables Mnb in our
function such that it's prediction is
more optimal,
Aka the error is smallest,
but apartment prices don't just depend
on the price per square foot. Right.
Also included our different features like
the number of bedrooms and the number
of bathrooms as well as the average
price of homes within a mile.
If we factored in those features as well,
our regression line would
look more like this.
There are now multiple
variables to consider,
so we can call it a
multivariate regression problem.
The branch of math concerned with the
study of multivariate spaces and the
linear transformations between
them is called Linear Algebra.
It gives us a set of operations that we
can perform on groups of numbers known
as matrices are training set now becomes
an m by eye and matrix of em samples
that have I features instead of a
single variable with the weight.
Each of the features has a weight,
so that's an example of how three of the
four main branches of math dealing with
machine learning are used. But what
about the fourth probability? All right,
so let's just scratch this example.
What if instead of predicting the price
of an apartment we went to predict
whether or not it's in
prime condition or not,
we want to be able to classify a house
with the probability of it being prime or
not. Prime probability is the
measure of likelihood of something.
We can use it probabilistic technique
called logistic regression to help us do
this.
Since this time,
our data is categorical as in it
has different categories or classes.
Instead of predicting a
value, we're predicting the
probability of an occurrence.
Since the probability goes between
zero and 100 we can't use an infinitely
stretching line.
We're left with some
threshold past some point x.
We are more likely than not
looking at a prime house.
We'll use an s shaped curve given
by the sigmoid function to do this.
Once we optimize our function,
we'll plug in input data and get a
probabilistic class value just like that.
So to summarize,
machine learning consist
mainly of statistics, calculus,
linear Algebra,
and probability theory.
Calculus tells us how to optimize linear
Algebra makes executing algorithms
feasible on massive datasets.
Probability helps predict the
likelihood of a certain outcome.
And statistics tells us what our goal is.
This week's coding challenge is to
create a logistic regression model from
scratch in python on
an interesting dataset.
Get humbling SCO in the common section.
And winners will be announced in a week.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to build a movement.
So thanks for walking.